- What'd you write?
- Tardiness.
- Oh please bitch, you're tardy all day.
- You always late.
- I am late but you late too.
- [Jackie] I know!
(soft music)
- Hi, my name is Diane Guerrero
and I'm at Buzzfeed today
and we're doing The Best Friend Test.
And that's Jackie Cruz.
- Don't like tell the truth.
(women laugh)
Don't be honest though.
- I don't know, let me see.
- Okay, one, two, three.
- [Jackie] Ha, ha, that's good too.
- What's that?
- That's good, dammit, that too.
I said eating salt and vinegar chips.
But that's good, I think
she's more right than I am.
- [Diane] Really, I know
this, I know her better.
- She knows me better than I do.
I will probably be making
coffee, she's right, dammit.
- Now don't show yet.
- I'm not.
I might be wrong.
- Okay.
(Jackie laughs)
- When do I ever?
- You always say (speaks foreign language)
She says it a lot,
(speaks foreign language)
- Yeah but fuck is classic,
this is like my word.
- That is classic but, I just,
- What do I like constantly
after every other word.
- (speaks foreign language)
- No I don't, she doesn't know me.
- I must not know her.
- Wow, cool, cool, cool,
wow, wow, wow, wow.
- But that's easy, I
thought we were going deep,
- Don't copy me.
- I'm not.
You can't cheat on this test.
We're already best friends.
- This was, this was like
a reach I don't know.
- I don't know if I,
She's a fashionista.
(girls laugh)
I said braiding hair, do you
spell braiding like that?
- When the hell have you ever braid?
- I cornrow.
- I would love for you to cornrow my hair.
- I would love for you
to give me some rows.
- Alright, you know I could cornrow.
- I had no idea.
- Oh my gosh.
Well shit yours is way long.
(girls laugh)
- What?
- Coffee breathe.
- Oh I do hate coffee
breath, but that's you,
that's for you.
- I didn't know.
- [Diane] Wow.
- But I did get a mint today.
- We're not, I just thought
we were best friends.
- [Jackie] We're not in tune.
- I thought we were right
here but we're not here.
- [Jackie] We're not in tune.
- Wow.
- Next question please?
- My god, let's just get one please, god,
or else this is all a sham.
- Yeah, no, we haven't gotten one yet.
(playful music)
The scene?
- Oh, oh I got it.
- Oh wait.
Hold on, can I see?
What was so funny?
- And Jackie we're supposed
to show it together
at the same time.
- Well you're the one who shows it first.
- No I don't, you do.
- One, two, three.
Our outfits.
They're kind of fun.
- Yeah but this was hilarious
when you were trying
to smize and she didn't know how to,
it was like smizing.
Remember te-gen, uh.
- Come on, let's get this one right.
- Okay I'm trying.
- Can we like.
- No.
You know what my guilty pleasure is.
Alright go.
- What?
- Let me see.
- [Both] Bob's Burger.
- Just 'cause you love
to watch Bob's Burger.
- I do but that's not like
my, I'm not guilty about it.
- Okay.
- I'm very proud, I would never ever.
- [Jackie] Junk food?
- Yeah you see me like scarf down Doritos
and that stuff.
- But that's not,
- The soda and all that stuff.
- Yeah but you don't
feel guilty after though.
- Yes I do.
- I didn't know she felt guilty.
- I feel guilty sometimes about it.
- She loves them candies.
- Yo.
- Oh we need to write it down.
- Jesus.
- I'm so sorry I forgot about the game.
- But don't write that
down because that's not it.
- Okay, that's not it.
- Oh, if you don't get this,
then our friendship is freaking over.
Alright, I wrote, you already wrote to,
- Ew!
- You know I go for the donuts.
- Whatever!
- Chips.
- We don't even have
that many donuts on set.
- When we do I eat them, but
I guess I eat them in secret.
- Yeah but that's like
once in a blue moon like.
Well she eats them in secret,
how'm I supposed to know?
Oh come on.
- Please.
- Can I give you a hint?
- No.
- Okay.
- Wait can she give me a hint?
(Jackie laughs)
No.
Okay.
Ready?
- Come on.
(Jackie laughs)
- Pretty Woman, I know you're right.
I should have known that.
- I do love Selena but Pretty Woman.
- I know it's your favorite movie, I know.
- Okay she knew that one.
- Sorry.
(upbeat music)
- Oh you know this.
- I do?
Alright ready?
- Yes.
(girls shout)
Finally.
- Okay.
- We can be friends again.
- And he's dead.
- Yeah it's okay, it's still celebrity.
- What's yours?
Angelic vocals?
Oh my god that is so cute.
- You're welcome.
- See a lot of people
don't know this about me.
- What is it?
The coolest person ever.
- Yeah, people know you're super cool
but I feel like people don't
think that I'm as cool.
- No you're cooler than I am.
- Yes but that's a secret.
- That's a secret.
- Okay this is bad.
(Jackie laughs)
- What is that?
Oh really?
When have you ever sent me that?
- I don't, I don't know that.
- No actually, you send me this one.
- What the hell is that?
- These are the hands
that go up like this.
- Oh yeah.
- Terrible drawing.
- Those look like wings.
We should stick to acting.
- We don't know anything about each other.
- This is really bad.
I don't think we could
be best friends anyway.
- You ruined our lives.
- Yeah you ruined our friendship.
Well I definitely learned a lot today
about things that I should have known.
- Well I just yeah, we
just need to start like
paying attention to each other a lot more.
- Yeah, because the little
things are the most important.
- Yeah and it's like if we have
to work on our relationship
that's what we learned.
- Absolutely.
Thank you.
- Thanks.
- I'm so thankful for Buzzfeed
for giving me the opportunity
to learn these things.
- Thank you for
- [Both] Giving me the opportunity.
(Jackie laughs)
(whooshes)
(squeaks)